Hi. I’m John Green, this is Crash Course
World History and today's video is kind of
a response to one of the most riveting history
books you'll ever read, the Columbian Exchange
by David Crosby. He had a good year in 1969--
published The Columbian Exchange, played Woodstock,
he was still on his first liver. What? It
was Albert Crosby? Gash! History, never being
as interesting as I want it to be.
Right, so it was Alfred Crosby Jr., and in
that book he wrote, "The big questions are
really the only ones worth considering, and
colossal nerve has always been a prerequisite
for such consideration." I love it!
Before 1492, we couldn't really talk about
a world history at all, we could only talk
about the different histories of separate
regions, but Columbus changed all of that,
and everything else. The Columbian Exchange
irrevocably homogenized the world's biological
landscape. Since Columbus, the number of plant
and animal species has continually diminished,
and the variation in species from place to
place has diminished dramatically. I mean,
the first European visitors to the Americas
had never seen a tomato or a catfish; Native
Americans had never seen a horse, and by making
our planet biologically singular, the Columbian
Exchange completely remade the populations
of animals, particularly humans. And vitally,
this cross-pollination also made possible
such wonders as contemporary pizza.
[theme music]
So we're going to break the Columbian Exchange
down into four categories: Diseases, boy,
you're looking good Smallpox, I'm glad you've
been eliminated; Animals, Plants, and People.
Mr. Green, Mr. Green! People are animals.
Yeah, that's true, me from the past, but just
for the sake of simplicity we're--
Also, when you think about it, microbes are
kinda animals and plants are, too, I mean--
Oh my god, shut up before I kill you and create
a time travel paradox.
Microbes, like those hairy blokes back there,
were a definite negative in terms of the Columbian
Exchange. Terminology is hard here, but the
majority of Caribbean Islanders or Native
Americans or Amerindians had exactly one response
to the arrival of Europeans: death.
We can't be sure of how many natives died
as a result of European arrival but it was
definitely more than 50% and some estimates
place it as high as 90%. Historians used to
blame European brutality, which was definitely
a factor, but the main culprit was disease.
Smallpox is usually seen as the villain of
the story but it is more likely that a series
of diseases in combination did the damage.
Along with smallpox, Americans were killed
by measles and mumps, typhus, chicken pox,
none of which they had been previously exposed
to. This astonishing decrease of population
was definitely the worst effect of these diseases,
both psychologically and demographically.
But the secondary effects were almost as bad.
For one thing the deaths of Aztec and Incan
rulers touched off wars which made it easier
to spread disease, because you know, the number
one way to catch smallpox is via hand-to-hand
combat. Plus leaders kept dying. Huayna Capac,
the leader of the Incan empire, succumbed
to smallpox before Pizarro even arrived. His
death led to a violent succession struggle
between his sons which was won by Atahualpa,
who in turn was captured and killed by Pizarro.
And without that war, the Inca would have
had a much better chance against the Spaniards,
whose numbers were comparatively tiny. A similar
thing happened to the Aztecs. The Moctezuma
who eventually lost to Cortés was the nephew
of a much more powerful king who died of smallpox.
And the death of that great king encouraged
some of the smaller states in the Aztec empire to rebel,
and some of them even fought for the Spaniards.
And another effect of disease was starvation,
because there simply weren't enough people
left to grow crops to feed the living. And
the malnutrition made survivors that much
more susceptible to disease. In short, it
sucked.
The transmission of disease largely went one
way, from the Old World to the New, but the
Americans did have one gift for Europe: venereal
syphilis. It showed up in Europe around 1493,
and even though Europeans are very fond of
ascribing syphilis to each other: Italians
called it the French disease; the French called
it the disease of Naples; Poles called it
the German disease; Russians called it the
Polish disease. The truth is, venereal syphilis
was spread by sailors who'd returned from
the Americas.
In fact, in his book, The Columbian Exchange,
Crosby tells it like this: "Sailors, by the
nature of their profession, are men without
women and therefore men of many women. We
can imagine no group more perfectly suited
for guaranteeing that venereal syphilis would
have worldwide distribution." Who says history
books are boring? Syphilis would go on to
infect a veritable who's who of Europe: from
Baudelaire to Gauguin to Nietzsche, not to
mention numerous family members of the famously
infertile Tudor and Valois families, meaning
that syphilis may be responsible for many
of those miserably boring dynastic power struggles
of post-Columbus Europe. Anyway, nothing against
syphilis, but it pales in comparison to the
devastation wrought by Old World diseases
arriving in the New World.
But the New World did have one gift for the
Old World that was pretty destructive: tobacco.
Oh, it's time for the open letter and there's
been a costume change? That doesn't bode well.
An Open Letter to Tobacco.
But first let's see what's in the secret compartment
don't be cinnamon don't be cinnamon don't
be -- dang it!
I guess that I'm going to do the cinnamon
challenge. Oh, I am not happy about this Stan,
for the record -- alright, I'm going to do
the cinnamon challenge: one tablespoon of
cinnamon in my mouth, no water.
Huh, boy, that -- that sucked. I, I uh regret
r-regret doing that to be honest with you.
Dear Tobacco,
I just did something really stupid but at
least it was cheap. I'm gonna tell you two
stories about smoking, the first come from
my high school history teacher Raoul Meyer
who also writes Crash Course. When I was a
senior in high school he walked up to me and
he said, "I want you to keep smoking. I want
you to smoke until the day after your 65th
birthday, and then I want you to die so that
I collect all of your social security." That inspired me,
Mr. Meyer, to quit smoking just eight short years later.
Here is an amazing statistic: cigarettes were
handed out to American servicemen during World
War II and more soldiers who started smoking during
the war died from smoking than died from the war.
So if the New World was looking to extract
some measure of revenge for smallpox, and
measles, and chicken pox: Mission accomplished.
Best Wishes,
John Green
Now onto animals. American animals, like llamas
and guinea pigs, never really caught on in
Eurasia. But imports to the Americas, like
pigs, cows and horses were revolutionary.
Let's go to the thought bubble:
First of all, these animals, especially pigs,
completely remade the food supply. Pigs breed
really quickly, they eat anything and they
turn into bacon, which made them heroes to
the new world just as today they are heroes
to the internet. Here's how quickly pigs breed:
When Hernando de Soto arrived in Florida in
1539, he brought 13 pigs. By the time of his
death, there were 700 - that was 3 years later.
The abundance of meat and plentiful land for
agriculture and grazing meant that Europeans
in the Americas very rarely experienced famine,
and despite what you may have learned about
religious and political freedom, the main
reason Europeans came to America was to eat.
Large European animals also changed the nature
of work in the Americas. Before Europeans,
the largest beast of burden was the llama,
and at best it could carry like, 100 lbs.
This meant that for the long distance travel
that the Inca engaged in, the primary transportation
animal was Incas. Oxen, when combined with
their plows, made it possible to bring more
land under cultivation and also made transportation
easier and more efficient, and plus European
animals remade culture.
The grossly stereotypical American Indian,
like from the movies, riding the Great Plains
with an eagle feather headdress and war paint,
well he didn't exist before the Columbian
Exchange because there were no horses for
him to ride. And the introduction of horses
allowed many Native Americans to abandon agriculture
in favor of a nomadic lifestyle because riding
around hunting buffalo made them far richer
than farming ever had. Thanks Thought Bubble.
While animals and diseases completely reshaped
the New World, it was New World plants that
had the biggest effect on Eurasia.
Sure, Europeans brought over some crops that
we now grow here in the Americas like wheat
and grapes, both of which are necessary for
Catholic mass, but New World plants radically
changed the lives of millions, maybe hundreds
of millions of Africans, Asians and Europeans,
specifically by making pizza possible.
[Heavenly singing, "It was the greatest gift
of all."]
I mean until 500 years ago Italians lived
without tomatoes, without modern pizza or
marinara sauce or pizza or ketchup or pizza
or even pizza. Indians lived without curry,
which contains chilies, a New World food.
Persians lived without corn, which is a New
World food, as are beans and potatoes and
avocados and peanuts and blueberries - the
list goes on and on.
And these New World crops led to probably
the greatest population increase in history.
To quote Crosby, "It is crudely true that
if man's caloric intake is sufficient, he
will somehow stagger to maturity, and he will
reproduce."
And New World food was far more caloric than
Old World food, which is the central reason
that the world population doubled between
1650 and 1850. Plants like corn and potatoes
could grow in soils that were useless for
Old World crops. Potatoes were actually introduced
to Europe as an aphrodisiac, but it turns
out that you have to distill those potatoes
into vodka before they have the desired effect.
Anyway, if potatoes are an aphrodisiac, the
Irish quickly became the hottest people on
Earth.
An acre and a half of potato cultivation could
feed an Irish family for a year, and the average
Irish worker often ate 10 lbs. of potatoes
every day. Surviving primarily on potatoes,
the Irish more than doubled their population
between 1754 and 1845, when the Potato Famine
showed up and ruined everything.
And it wasn't just Europe. Manioc, or cassava
is a New World plant with roots that provide
more calories than any other plant on Earth,
provided they are properly processed (otherwise
they're poisonous). Manioc is so prevalent
in Africa that many Africans swear that the
plant is native to the continent, but it isn't.
Nor are sweet potatoes, and while New World
grains never replaced rice in Southeast, or
East Asia, the sweet potato was so common
that it is known as the "poor person’s staple"
in China. Even in Japan, the tomb of the farmer
who is reputed to have first brought them
to the islands is known as the Temple of the
Sweet Potato. And it's also worth noting that
corn, while it may not feature prominently
in European diets, has been the central source
of food for animals in Europe for centuries.
And in fact, that's still the case. In 2005,
58% of the corn grown in America went to animal
feed (is the kind of thing you learn when
you live in Indiana).
Alright, so last but not least, the Columbian
exchange involved the transfer of lots of
people. Again, in the early stages this movement
was mostly one way, with Europeans and Africans
- the Africans usually against their will
- making their way to the Americas.
So the Columbian Exchange led to the re-population
of the New World following the disease devastation
of the initial encounter. And better nutrition
allowed the population of the Old World to
grow which in turn placed population pressure
on Eurasia which led to more people coming
to the Americas. In the process, the world's
human inhabitants became more genetically
and ethnically interconnected. But it also
led to the horrors of Atlantic slavery, which
we'll be discussing next week.
What are we to make of the Columbian Exchange?
It devastated the population of the Americas,
it led to the widespread slavery of Africans,
but it also allowed for a worldwide population
increase and the lives of some Natives including
Plains tribes like the Lakota became better
and more secure, at least for a while.
Fewer people have starved since the Columbian
Exchange began, but the diversity of life on
Earth has diminished dramatically and planting crops
where they don't belong has hurt the environment.
So on the whole, should we be grateful for
the Columbian Exchange? And should we work
to continue and deepen its legacy of globalism
and monoculture?
Crosby didn't think we were better off. "The
Columbian Exchange has included man, and he
has changed the Old and New Worlds sometimes
inadvertently, sometimes intentionally, often
brutally. It is possible that he and the plants
and animals he brings with him have caused
the extinction of more species of life forms
in the last four hundred years than the usual
processes of evolution might kill off in a
million... The Columbian Exchange has left
us with not a richer but a more impoverished
genetic pool. We, all of the life on the planet,
are the less for Columbus, and the impoverishment
will increase."
But let's give you the last word today: Do
you agree with Crosby? Are longer, healthier
lives for more humans worth the sacrifice
of an impoverished biosphere? And most importantly,
how will your conclusions about those questions
shape the way that you live your life?
Thanks for watching. I'll see you next week.
Crash Course is produced and directed by Stan
Muller. Our script supervisor is Danica Johnson.
The show is written by my high school history
teacher, Raoul Meyer, and myself, and our
graphics team is Thought Bubble.
Last week’s phrase of the week was "Mario
and Luigi,” thanks for that suggestion.
If you want to suggest future phrases of the
week you can do so in comments or you can
also guess at this week’s phrase of the
week, and ask questions about today's video
that will be answered by our team of historians.
Thanks for watching Crash Course, and as we
say in my hometown, Don't Forget To Be Awesome.